-[ Laughs ]
Great one.
That was a great one, James.
Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
It is time to play "Pup Quiz"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Playing tonight, he is a baker,
he is an actor,
he is the star of the new
HBO series "The Deuce."
It is James Franco!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know her from "Keeping Up
With the Kardashians,"
she is a brand ambassador
for Adidas,
and one of the biggest
supermodels in the world,
Kendall Jenner,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And this is the first puppy
up for grabs tonight.
This is Gary Frick Jr.
Here's how the game works.
I'll be asking both of you
animal trivia questions.
If you answer correctly, you win
a golden retriever puppy.
[ Laughter ]
If you answer incorrectly,
your opponent gets the puppy.
James, you're up first.
Are you ready?
-I'm ready.
-What animal can climb higher
than any other on planet Earth,
and has been seen
at over 37,000 feet?
Is it A,
the Himalayan jumping spider?
Is it B, Ruppell's vulture?
Or is it C,
a wandering albatross?
They wander. They wander.
You don't know where
they're gonna end up.
-Ruppell's vulture.
-Ruppell's vulture sounds like
Rubik's Cube or something.
But, the answer is --
that is correct,
it is Ruppell's vulture.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Audience "awws" ]
[ Dogs barking ]
There you go.
Gary, having a good time there.
Okay, here we go.
Next question is for you,
Kendall.
What was the most popular name
for a female dog
in the United States last year?
Is it A, Luna?
Is it B, Bella?
Or is it C, Princess?
-I'm gonna go A, Luna.
-Why would you go with A, Luna?
-'Cause I had two friends
with two dogs named Luna.
-Well, there you go.
Well, it's the most popular --
-So there's are two people
already.
-Most popular in your world,
yeah.
-Okay, so sorry.
[ Laughter ]
-That is incorrect.
I'm so sorry.
[ Buzzer ]
The correct answer is Bella.
-That was my second answer.
-James, you get another puppy.
-No!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I knew this was gonna happen.
-Are you jealous?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, yeah.
Two puppies in there --
there you go.
[ Laughter ]
[ Dogs barking ]
Perfect, all right.
-Watch me get no puppies
out of this.
-That sound means
it's time for Double Puppardy.
[ Laughter ]
Questions are now worth
two puppies.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-The next question is for you --
-These puppies are going nuts.
-The next question is for you,
James.
-Okay.
-In a recent scientific study,
researchers discovered that
cows produce the most milk
while listening to
which one of these songs?
Is it A, "Single Ladies"
by Beyoncé?
Is it B, "Thriller"
by Michael Jackson?
Or is it C, "Everybody Hurts"
by R.E.M.?
[ Laughter ]
-Beyoncé, "Single Ladies."
-That would be incorrect.
[ Buzzer ]
It is "Everybody Hurts"
by R.E.M.
That means Kendall gets
two puppies.
[ Cheers and applause ]
There is Peter Winston
and Lisa Armstrong.
-Yay!
That's the name of these
puppies, right here.
There you go, Kendall, see?
-Hey, guys.
-Yeah, yeah, all right.
This is neck and neck.
This game is neck and neck.
Kendall,
the next question is for you,
and this, or course,
is the goldendoodle round.
[ Laughter ]
This question is
a hybrid of a dolphin
and a false killer whale
is known as a what?
A, a wholphin.
[ Laughter ]
B, a dorca.
Or C, a dolphale.
-Uh, B?
-A dorca?
-Dorca?
-Judges?
Incorrect.
[ Buzzer ]
I'm so sorry. It is a wholphin,
is what it was called.
Say hello to Carl Finston
and Fin Carlston.
That's out two pups --
goldendoodles.
They're goldendoodles.
They'll get along with
your other dogs.
[ Dogs barking ]
There you go, James.
I don't know if --
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
There you go, I don't know.
There you go.
[ Puppy barking ]
What?
Oh, you know what
that sound means.
It's time for Final Puppardy.
[ Laughter ]
This is for all of
your opponent's puppies.
[ Audience "awws" ]
Now, this is for all of --
[ Laughter ]
Fin, Fin, calm down.
Fin, calm down.
Fin, Fin, hey, Fin, please,
have respect for yourself.
Fin, stop, stop it.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
-All right,
now you need to pick a --
[ Laughter ]
Fin, Fin, stop right now.
James, you need to pick up
this iPad right here.
Here's the iPad.
You need this iPad here.
-I have no hands.
-Here you go.
There's an iPad for you.
Kendall, you got yours.
-Yeah.
-All right, here we go.
Now, this is a numbers question.
You will write your answers
down...
-Oh, no.
[ Laughter ]
-...and whoever is closest to
the correct answer
is the Pup Quiz champion.
Okay, here we go.
Here's the question.
Roughly how many pigeons
live in New York City?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, man.
-I mean, a lot of people
live here.
How many pigeons,
roughly, live here?
That's a lot of pigeons,
I would say.
You have 10 seconds,
I forgot to tell you that,
starting now.
Sorry, we're out of time almost.
Oh, we're almost --
we have seven seconds left.
-Oh, my God.
-We have six seconds left.
Hold on to your puppies.
[ Laughter ]
Nope, I was talking to James.
I was talking --
[ Buzzer ]
All right, here we go. Okay.
All right,
what did you write down?
James, what was your answer?
-Wait, wait.
-That was crazy.
-[Bleep] Sorry.
There we go.
-I think it's two million?
-I thought I was on "The Deuce."
-Two million, yeah.
And you just -- you said a curse
word in front your puppies.
[ Laughter ]
Kendall,
what did you write down?
-10 million.
-10 million?
The answer is four million.
James is the winner.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm so sorry, Kendall.
I hate --
I hate to do this to you,
you have to
say goodbye to your puppies.
-No!
-Come here, pal.
[ Audience "awws" ]
Here you go.
[ Laughter ]
There you go.
Kendall, I'm sorry, but this one
has to come with me.
-Bye, buddy.
-You know the rules of the game.
You know the rules of the game.
There you go.
-Got me all hairy.
-Perfect. The winner right
there, James Franco.
But my thanks to Kendall Jenner
and all of these
adorable puppies.
We're talking to Kendall
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
We'll be right back.
Stay there.
Sit, stay.